i still live in media
fine i'll do the [ __ ] intro all right
this is another podcast our guest
is open mike eagle we recorded this in a
hotel room in butler
pennsylvania during the let's see how
this goes tour
so check out the podcast open mic eagles
new album
anime trauma and divorce is available
now on all of us
[Music]
should have been cool but dude got
screwed up his [ __ ] got burned up so he
[ __ ] her up and she turned big
i got chewed up that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up
so imma [ __ ] you up a kid called him
that kid grew up and messed this kid up
he [ __ ] her [ __ ] up then she [ __ ]
up it all got screwed up and that [ __ ]
me up so i'ma [ __ ] you up
so get that and i'll be performing
october 24th
at the rose bowl in pasadena with
thundercat
tickets are available for the early show
daytime
4 30 p.m on a saturday
uh in the parking lot it's not gonna
happen again
check it out with that being said
this thing's stolen twenty dollars for
me over the years at least
i wonder i wonder if my brain has gone
short circuit from this level of
consistent
activity you know what i'm saying
because to go from nothing
yeah yeah and then back-to-back days
even the days where
the rare days where i've had a lot of
activity or
you know creative stuff going that day
it's been
you know a day after that but now i was
like oh god boom
gig travel stuff filming it's
it's exciting it is it's hard to explain
to people uh
like why i'm busy right now
to explain to people because it just
sounds ridiculous yeah
i'm sorry uh i'm touring drive-ins right
now
and it's really [ __ ] weird so i have
to uh
i have to give you got to give me a beat
to answer this email real quick
yeah it's it's nice to not
be all the way tapped in
as i've been because he had i had to
snap out of it
i put together a small shoot the other
day in chicago
and it was it was nice to do something
oh yeah i don't
my main thing is not uh emails and [ __ ]
and no video calls but i almost got
fooled or shifted into oh yeah this and
then
when i started you know recording stuff
i do oh yeah yeah
yeah this is better what was i thinking
do you find it like hard to duck people
right now because
they just assume that you're not doing
[ __ ] like especially when you're not on
the road like
if you duck them like it's like uh this
is the thing though
so it you know right so people do tend
to assume you're available right now
yeah but look this is a perfect way you
get out of anything
like in the pandemic yeah right you say
hey
look at the flyer no no no i'm talking
about it ain't [ __ ] going on right we
was all still sitting at home if you
want to duck people you say
hey i'm depressed yeah [ __ ] works
it is true and the [ __ ] works every time
people leave you the [ __ ] alone
if you tell them you're too sad for life
nobody ever says yo
do some jumping jacks or play some
here's here's a playlist
actually man i got a close homie he told
me um
he said do some exercise drink water
bust some nuts and talk to your friends
that's his
that was his advice that's solid advice
that's yeah yeah that is the advice
yeah i'm cool with all of it except to
talk to the people talk to people apart
yeah yeah i've been avoiding talking to
people too yeah
yeah yeah sometimes yeah i'll talk to
some folks but
it'll be sometimes where i'm like nope
gonna sit here
angry for a bit
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and in my head this other voice yo you
should you
some folks you trust you some folks you
guys good friends
you should hit one of them up they
if you call three people well somebody's
picking up
out of the three probably no matter what
you gonna
nop i'm gonna sit here angry maybe this
video get this video game will fix it
video games video games man all-time
high right now yeah i love them
i love them they they saved my life
savior you know what i mean
playing overwatch playing um i'm playing
tony hawk man
tony hawk i'm on that tony hawk oh
that's tony hawk and feels like old
school is there a new version it's
remastered
yeah remix remastered yeah reissued it's
faster the graphics is better
it's nice it's the same it's the same
song playlist with like added songs
oh yeah yeah it's crazy it reminds me of
college
and get that muscle memory going yeah
yeah zone it yeah
so just for context for the listeners
that might be
just you know not knowing even though
we'll
surely put it in the description and
whatnot we're on the road
uh on uh we just finished the second
date of the
let's see how this goes tour with
myself over my eagle tony trim
uh brian babylon and uh a new associate
uh dj carson miller also performed and
we did a
one show in uh cleveland was the opening
show
and wow wow
there was a lot of things that happened
uh in cleveland it was it was an
interesting
interesting show um you want to describe
i feel like you should describe it for
people you probably had the best
yeah great i had the most going on
so that was the first show
didn't really there's some comedy clubs
open but i didn't want to go to the
comedy clubs to prep
uh we did a little bit of a run through
the night before at north bar
in chicago thank you to jim weber over
there for uh
letting us into space and that was it
was a fun time
it was weird to work on the show just be
at the bars you know it was tony
kelvin uh justin was there
izzy did the voice overs and uh
some it was it was a nice time this is a
cool way to
it felt good tony it was like this is a
nice way to kick off tour yeah
you know it's like all the you know all
the old friends and [ __ ] everybody's
together he jim opened the bar he was
just like
very gracious like yeah let's let's do
it yeah it's like a celebration almost
yeah like we're going to send off worked
on some cues and whatnot and then
oh that venue adding that
you in fact performing with the highway
in your direct eye line not even direct
eye line
just actually a little bit up so it's
like
perfectly it's right there
cleveland was was wild it wasn't even
because the way this place is positioned
i loved how you said you're performing
uh by the highway yes that that is not
something that you hear often you know
we're doing a show about the highways
hella trucks
like just non-stop trucks non-stop
trucks and just right
and you think about just you know
mentally for stand up
someone said was prepared but in certain
zones
that don't have trucks it can be easy to
kind of
get in a in a zone and and create on a
fly right
but it's tough when it's that much
information
going past words
i'm already like this is weird so
there's already a lot to think about
well i mean i think i think more more so
is like
there was completely no visual it was
like staring into abyss
and the only thing you could see is the
lights on the cars and trucks going by
so
it felt even more jarring because i feel
like that's all you saw
yeah you couldn't see people you can see
reactions nothing
yeah i mean and that's that's something
i feel like people have been asking me a
lot about
is like what is the experience like
performing on stage at a drive-in and
like that's
especially cleveland it felt so
strange because it's just a sea of like
black
car shapes yeah yeah and there's no you
know
there were some people up at the very
front but it was just like a sea
of dark ovals like it felt like
post-apocalyptic a little bit
it did it felt it felt mad weird and and
so like
that in itself is like very disorienting
uh
just as in your field of view but then
yeah on the left side you got the
highway
and then uh on the right side hella
trains
obscene hella trains and just
it was i knew after two that it was
gonna be
a lot i knew that after the second one i
said this is not
i'm this is still this is gonna be a
part of tonight
it's not over at two i don't know how
many it is but it ain't
it ain't just two it ain't three it's
gonna be it's
it's about to go crazy but did you like
clock the trains before you got up did
you know or
were you no i saw the tracks i think but
i didn't know it was gonna
did i even see the traffic i don't even
i didn't remember if i mentioned them
doing a sound check
uh but well they weren't passing over
sound checking for sure because we would
have noticed it
uh yeah it was it was weird man it was a
it was
it was like train rush hour though i
think yeah it did seem like it picked up
a little bit because that was not
happening
during any of the other times i think
like it your set was
trained matter of fact the first time it
happened when you was on
i hadn't even noticed that there were
train tracks yeah me neither
over there so like when i heard that
noise i felt like we were being attacked
i felt like there was something about to
land on us
it was it was very scary before i
realized that that was
a locomotive yeah man
that was it was a lot it was a it was a
yeah nothing nothing
i i won't ever have a show
like that again yeah because now that's
a new thing for any
outdoor show what's the train track
situation
what's the highway sight line think
about
when a comedy show you've been to
where i'm gonna [ __ ] just get up and
go to the bathroom and the
comics like well you're gonna take a
[ __ ] huh where you going you know like
i'm gonna fix it on that thing about
who's the christian bale that just got
mad about
a human being being in his eye line
right he was trying to
christ losing his [ __ ] on a movie set
because he's in the crew he was in
character and somebody was in his eye
line or something
and he just for his process he's just
snapped that's just a human on a movie
set
so he's not doing stand up
it's just trucks he's like oh man i
don't know what else
this is the most important thing right
now because that's what uh
that's how the uh adhd brain is like the
most important thing
or the whatever's in your face it can
that it makes that
the most important thing so there's no
wave to ride whereas like a show going
well
and you kind of kill it in the pocket
and
getting the laps then that's the most
important thing is maintaining
the [ __ ] wave but if the [ __ ] is
broken ain't nothin
another fedex truck that's number three
so
you talked about you talked about what
you can see yeah um
but you just mentioned getting the
feedback from the laughter and how
important that is
so like that first show
how how did were you able to hear people
laughing
not really
there's a couple of woos and children
yeah i couldn't hear how
stuff really hit
at all um there was no
yeah there was no feel maybe we need to
mic
two cars
[Laughter]
when you when you were when you were
listening to the vocals
in the car during sound check yeah what
did that what did that like did it just
feel like super immersive did it feel
super intimate like what did that feel
like it sounded
good but then i think
from it's one of those things from an
audience standpoint
um this is probably is not
conducive to being vocally reactive if
you're in the car
listening you're right
sticking your hand out it's like it
might feel like if you were like
laughing at the radio
yes it's really it's really that so
i was telling mike it's for his fans or
people just listening to him
they must feel like just listening to a
live concert on cd
right right you know what i'm saying
yeah um yeah it's a lot
you know but then you know butler
whole different approach to the show and
sound system yeah
the sound system was key and even
karshmallow was i could see he was
feeling his stride now we got to set the
scene for butler though
we can't just go from cleveland to
butler okay i'm talking about
butler okay like because yeah yeah
questions yeah we all questions butler
people message me a lot yeah why do you
why do you want to go to
why are you going to butler there is a
pittsburgh butler has
trump people there it's elias trump
county are you gonna be do you might get
i'm like damn they gonna start a clan
rally at the merch table or something
the way
man they really made this seem like a
dangerous place you made that video
uh saying you know you what was it i
don't know
butler the song yeah fella pennsylvania
where the [ __ ] is that
i don't know i never been there yeah and
you put that video out and i'm i'm
retweeting it trying to uh promote the
show too
and like so i don't know nothing about
butler before
you make the song and put this video out
and i'm retweeting it
and like every other comment that came
back was like
yo yeah butler's [ __ ] racist
you know what i mean i'm like learning
about the place
like while we're promoting the show and
i am
certainly getting uh getting anxious
about what we're going to expect when we
get here
it was yeah they really they made it
seem
we saw the when we saw the biting office
yeah when we first pulled into town is
we saw a bite in office so that was
the first time it was comforting to see
his name
i don't know why but we're not gonna die
there's a bite in office there and then
we saw the store uh
brandon brown we saw jesus
we got really excited yeah suddenly we
knew
we got a [ __ ] three grown ass man got
excited about seeing yeezys in the
window
everything's right that's how desperate
we are for some kind of normalcy in this
western pennsylvania we was not
expecting to see no using no
easy store at all and they had like
every model in the way they had oh yeah
they had all kinds of yeezys and
like we got to stop in here we gotta we
gotta go see what the hell this is
not so bad after all so in that store
uh oh boy hooked us up with shirts yeah
which is
just which was cool got some you know
stage wear where
uh got some food and then
food was decent too food was decent
prepared for the gig got to the venue
and uh things felt different on the way
though between yeah between downtown
butler
and then the further we went towards
whether because it ain't [ __ ] by these
drive-ins so far at least two for two
you know cleveland and butler these
drive-ins ain't buy nothing
right so we we out by nothing uh
butler pennsylvania's nothing and it got
it got real trump real fast
it was some big sign it was big it was
it wasn't a normal lawn sign
it was a big like is that a family
member a sign
yeah is that one of his folks do you
remember the first one that i clocked it
was like it was a corner house yeah
there was like five flags
flags american it was a trump flag
confederate flag
american flag another trump flag
confederate flag
big as [ __ ] these were extra large flags
these weren't
and they looked like they were packing
heat they looked like there was guns in
that house
they were sitting they were hanging out
outside no i'm just saying it looked
like that because
yeah confederate flag you gotta just
assume that they're nra
and then on the way out um you know we
passed a gas station i think that has
like a trump office
connected to it so we saw a buying
office and then we saw they dedicated a
whole building to that track campaign
out in the woods and [ __ ] um so yeah by
the time we get back to the venue i'm
anxious all over again after downtown to
calm me down a little bit
but uh but butler was fun though
it was fun it was a good show fun show
it's a fun show
like they had a bar there they didn't
care people was drinking to drive it man
i didn't even think about that cleveland
was like no
alcohol butler was like here's the
alcohol yeah there
i don't even put two and two together oh
you're in the car you got here in the
car
you're gonna leave in the car
hey but that's that's the right way to
do it
i didn't even think that's hilarious
that's the to deal with it though
but yeah man butler butler butler was a
good time
yeah the sound yeah everything yeah it
was good it was good
it's good i got hype doing car smells
set
yeah you [ __ ] you were killing you
pretty much was performing with him
yeah just the theme and the concept and
what he stands for
i just got really hyped by it that's
really good at you to just
get out there and do that with him i
know carsonmellow's a real big artist
and he needs no introduction but just
you know for the few people listening
who haven't
heard of him he doesn't need it but go
ahead oh it's good just for the sake of
listeners at home it could be people
you know carmelo is uh is a world famous
dj
that has joined us on the tour and he
only plays
songs about being in a car or driving a
car
and you'd be surprised how many good
songs that is it's a lie
it's a lot of stuff a lot of really good
i was like there's no way he's gonna do
fill a whole 25 minutes and he he did it
he did
and he's got a costume and uh he's a
real fly dude man
he even like crammed uh like a mega mix
at the end
like it was like five five minute finale
and it was all
it was like ten car songs just jammed
into
his last three minutes wow that's how
many car songs there are out there
it's amazing i wonder what didn't make
the cut you know
when he was really cause i'm sure he was
super
meticulous about the playlist and and
probably started with
200 songs to get it down to that and
it's all like rap songs right
i don't think it's too much no at the
end there was a bunch of uh
random stuff but yeah mostly it was rap
yeah mostly as rap man
you know rappers like to talk about
their cars it's an honor to work with
that he's so gracious too like
opening up the show when he could be
like you know some
places he's a headline yeah you know
he's just doing it for fun and
and you got to really appreciate it i
think he also wanted to just kind of
that pandemic [ __ ] pandemic [ __ ] got you
you yeah he was doing the dj business is
kind of
slow like all aspects of entertainment
but i think he
you know wanted to get off of the
streaming he was doing a lot of twitch
streams and stuff
and those were lucrative for him but
didn't get the energy so
shout outs man i pitched it to him like
that and as the opportunity to get out
there and let the fans
see him again and luckily he he took it
so
um shout outs it's weird that he charged
me
it was a tough deal to close up he said
90
of all my future publishing and
royalties
uh that's a weird deal that's weird that
he would involve
future stuff that don't have nothing to
do with him i wouldn't have took the
deal but
you know what i'm just blessed to be a
part of it i mean you got to be glad
that
that hannibal did take the deal though i
just think
if these songs in the future do well or
they
did since he owned so much of them
he'd be incentivized to really
make them happen so that's why that's
smart i gave up the 90 percent
that's a car i think it's i think it's i
think it's worth it for the
experience for the for the fans it's a
that's really good if you man
90 is a lot of sense though that's
almost like the most percentage you can
get
like that's a lot yeah
i could see i see how you would yeah
come to that conclusion that 90 90 is a
lot
when you consider that did you try to
was it counter
flat did you try to counter did you or
you just said
90 no argument i think when you're
dealing with somebody like
that like harshmellow you just kind of
you let it go through and i could maybe
i don't think it would cover if i did
recordings other
under a pseudonym so maybe that would be
i'll give him i'll make sure but it's
the cars man
that's real true just one more question
did he start at 90
like when y'all's negotiating did he
start with 90. i think i kind of just
got nervous a little bit to be honest
and
and but the is having them on tour such
a
no regrets and i think we're going to do
a lot of cool work
together yeah okay y'all definitely vibe
on stage hard
yeah that was great it's a good idea i
was surprised he let you stay on stage
for so long i thought he was like
i was surprised like he doesn't i've
never seen him share a stage that long
i've seen like little
guest appearances but i've never seen
like just sharing the stage
so he must really like you you guys must
be tight uh
yeah he had a word with me
actually about that yeah that you were
what did he say
he said i was yelling too much oh boy
that's that's got to be weird for you to
be told at your own show that you can't
you know do whatever you want to do you
know that's awkward as [ __ ] right
to have him say that
i i get it though you know what i'm
saying it's just he want the music to
to yeah why why yell over
the tunes right and carmelo's about
music and cars and so
if i'm yelling then people can't hear
the music around there
he's been doing this for so long yeah
but i feel like you know what not no dis
the car smell or anything but i feel
like you enhance the set i think that
i think it was i think it was a way
better time that you were there so like
for him to trip like that
and look i got respect for crosstalk i'm
not talking [ __ ] sound like you're
talking a little [ __ ]
i'm not talking [ __ ] you know i got my
own personal you know
things about it but i you want to get
into that i mean to sound like you want
to say
i don't because i don't want to talk
[ __ ] because i don't want to feel like
you if you say something i mean are we
going to release this after the tour
because i don't want him to drop
off the tour then we putting this [ __ ]
out tomorrow yeah we're putting out
tomorrow yeah
well then i'm just going to keep that he
got he got to prove it too
i mean he's a cool guy man okay
that sounds i'm not that's i'm gonna
leave it there or no
anyway uh trim you're a dj yeah uh
and you you've been djing for hannibal
uh
during the lockdown yeah did you do a
lot of gigs at all did you do it i
did absolutely no gigs all i have been
doing
is trying to stay sane talking to my
dogs
and cooking okay that's all i've been
doing talking to you all i've been doing
and playing video games
uh and uh working on this cooking show
naturally
and the cooking show involves talking to
my dogs
cooking and talking okay
so yeah how about you do any new hobbies
uh new hobbies oh i've i've tried to
learn how to cook
i bought an air fryer and uh oh air
fryers are nice
yeah it's a good time hannibal put me on
to the air fryer oh yeah
at you know at my old house now i got a
new place i had to get a new
uh air fryer and so i've learned to cook
a few items
yeah what's the best one so far i'm like
pretty good at chicken wings
oh yeah yeah it's perfect for chicken
wings i'm pretty good at those now like
it's a nice crispy outside
my little cousin got me one of those for
christmas and i
use it for potatoes all day potatoes
toss them in a little oil salt and
pepper it's real that's it
okay throw that [ __ ] in the basket 10
minutes 400 degrees
comes out like crispy as [ __ ] and
they're healthy i like basket cooking
basket cooking that's a new that's a new
term right basket
basket cooking with that so with the air
fryer
yeah and wings or other
what's the learning curve or what's
what's the shifts i mean it's just the
seasoning levels
okay you know
i went a little hard with the red pepper
at first you know what i mean i had to
dial it back somehow i was burning some
people's mouths
okay you know well let's talk about the
the air fryer technology
right i don't understand how this [ __ ]
works at all all it is right
is this it's a basket that's suspended
inside of this machine
and it's a hot-ass cyclone of air
that just [ __ ] flies around the food
that seems like we should have figured
that [ __ ] out
a long time yeah i mean it's better than
microwaves right you know what i'm
saying like it doesn't make things mushy
it's just hot ass air
that flies around the food no no direct
fire
no liquids it's yeah
damn you can cook with anything you can
cook with water
yeah you can cook with gas you can cook
with fire
you can cook with radioactive waves you
can cook with dirt
really fermentation oh is is that
cooking yeah that's cooking that's
considered cooking
i didn't know that yeah that's that's
new information you could cook with
citrus
ceviche oh you just [ __ ] soak some
fish in some
some lemon lemon juice that [ __ ] comes
out cooked
i live in l.a i had that [ __ ] all the
time it's delicious it's the [ __ ]
ceviche is the [ __ ] hannibal what are
you doing to try to stay sane
over the overdue over i um
i'm trying to think of what the key for
my sanity
part was i kind of regret
not figuring out
early on just some type of controlled
consistent work or collaboration
situation
i look back at the time okay but
because i feel like at the beginning of
the situation there was this fear of
they made it
you might have it but you don't know you
know if you go to somewhere
you want are you sure you don't got it
because you might kill somebody
and so that's what kept me and
i think other folks in the house that
where
maybe i should have you know linked with
somebody that was
filming stuff early off or editor or
that and they're like all right this is
this is us
let's just make [ __ ] while this time you
know what i'm saying
yeah uh and that and in the times when i
have collaborated with people
you know and i think i started doing
stuff in june
when i'll go to studios and did it like
oh yeah this is
i need this this is this this is great
um so that's really it was like you know
no new hobbies a little as this a little
bit of cooking
started oh yeah i made the peanut butter
cups peanut butter cups
you made peanut butter cups oh that's
yeah yeah yeah
yeah this is on peanut butter cups now
how many do you make at one time
the first time i did six and they were
they were pretty big and
unhealthy but they were mine
they were mine is that a healthy peanut
butter cup
no they're i mean it's not a health but
there's one if it's healthy it's not
good right
it's got to be unhealthy yeah you
it's when i first bit it like this is a
lot i for real
i felt my chemistry change i really did
i felt it like a spike he was like
that's
that's not dude that's some real [ __ ]
i've had that happen man well you just
where you just taste something that's
too spicy too sweet too salty you're
like
and then your body like react physically
reacts like this
this is new i can handle it but i don't
want to
that's what happens to me when i eat
mcdonald's yeah
like i feel the sugar spike
and then i feel myself getting depressed
because all of the sugar leaves my body
at one time yeah
it was uh so that first that first batch
but it was it was a mixture of that and
pride
of the yeah about the chemistry chains
but also
i just made candy for the first time
what's the process of making a [ __ ]
peanut butter cup the making of peanut
butter cups
uh i found the recipe
on tick tock of course and he was just
making peanut butter cups 15 minutes
yeah and i said oh i'm interested what
peanut butter cups you talking about the
[ __ ] i've
probably spent thousands of dollars on
over the course of my life
i can make them myself i relish the
opportunity
and so it was the process is uh
you you get some chocolate chips
and you add butter and
peanut butter and then maybe some other
stuff to you know to sweeten
or or you know put in as at your own
leisure or whatever you you know
cinnamon or whatever some honey if you
want to throw that in and what that's
and so the one you melt the chocolate
in the microwave or over the stove stir
it up
and then you also
you have the butter and the peanut
butter you
melt the butter stir up the peanut
butter with it
put the melted chocolate in a muffin cup
or one of those
like put a little bit in as the base
then you put them in there
freeze them up for a little bit then you
come back in
then you take the peanut butter and
butter mixture
put that on top put it in the freezer
again
for a little bit and then come back in
have the chocolate on top of the peanut
butter
and then that's one way to do or you
could just do two s you know like peanut
butter bottle and peanut butter
i mean uh chocolate the bottom peanut
butter at the top at any freezing this
process did you get
uh did you get bored and just think
about just eating whatever the [ __ ] was
in front of you and saying [ __ ] the
recipe
like it's cramming all the [ __ ] in your
mouth right there
no no because it was just because i saw
it coming together
that's hilarious yeah let's call it a
day
[ __ ] this recipe
but man that [ __ ] that [ __ ] and then i
made that [ __ ] when i visited my sister
[ __ ]
you made it for the kids i made it for
the kids in my and they were
because i was over there doing they were
like what are you doing over there i'm
like yeah you see
[Laughter]
candy
he's like willy wonka that's the best
uncle ever status yeah
man and then i had you know i refined it
a little bit at that time and knew my
my portions a little bit better so it
wasn't diabetes
it's just reasonable candy
it's pretty good brother-in-law yeah
this is good everybody's like oh
i mean you got to bring that one for the
holidays that's a damn good hobby man
you made it sound like you wasn't doing
[ __ ] you cooking candy cooking candy
that was one day out of many dead zones
yeah
i had a couple highlight days
well hannibal's been doing some more
experimenting in the kitchen
tell the fans about the your new
sandwiches
well i don't think it's that uh
revolutionary experimental
i mean i enjoyed it with
so i went to i went to ralph's in la
before i was about to fly home to
chicago
pick up a prescription and then but i
went in ralph's hungry so even though i
had to fly that evening
i started just seeing junk food and [ __ ]
and reacting to it because i've been
doing most of my shopping on instacart
and i shop i think
with instacart do the grocery shopping
more practically
yeah and then you i need spinach i need
eggs i need this
juice a lot of all these items versus
when you go back into a store if you
ain't been in a store in a while
it's all this other [ __ ] that is pure
impulse you know like the candy and all
that [ __ ] that you like oh [ __ ]
you just react to and so i bought a
bunch of
i'm like some donuts but i was getting
ready to [ __ ]
fly in a few hours why did i buy a dozen
donuts
and i'm about to leave yeah i'm gonna
bring him in and so
it became a burden to me it came like i
said because a bigger problem in my head
than it really is but
i'm like this is i gotta figure out what
the [ __ ] i can't just leave these donuts
here
i don't wanna just put them in a bag and
carry them with me to the
how much were the donuts it was a few it
was donut prices like
ralph's donut prices prices yeah ralph's
he's like uh
but he's wearing like gourmet donuts no
no okay
but then i got to do something you know
what i'll use them as bread
and sandwich
[Laughter]
that'll knock out a couple
super healthy alternatives it's a
healthy alternative
turkey bacon was the first minute
skillet put the doughnuts
one doughnut and another donut two
doughnuts oh
not even cutting not even cut in half
the recipe evolved sandwich bro yeah it
evolved
now now i cut the doughnut in half but
the first the first go at it
it was two dollars it was going hard
but that [ __ ] tastes amazing because
donuts heated up it's just
yes yeah right now man you're talking
about that [ __ ] that's great
so mike this guy this guy hits me up on
the facetime
he's like look at this man and i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you doing
he's like i got the donut and then i got
some pad thai
yes yeah on the facetime
i'm like what is going on yeah
so you must have thought he was losing
his everlasting
they just things that seem like they
should but they do
it's just it's out of the box but it it
makes sense to
have if you don't have a sandwich to
have the bread a little bit sweet
like no i want this born ass bread or do
you want the best bread ever you want
you want this regular bread or do you
want glazed bread
i ain't even you know i never really
been a bread fan
uh you know tom papa yeah
so he does a podcast now where he
you know talks to people just like every
other [ __ ] podcast
but like he sends you bread that he
makes
oh that's awesome yeah and like when he
first told me he was going to send me
some bread i was kind of like no
i don't want no [ __ ] bread i don't
even eat bread like that like
some good ass artisan bread weird food
to my house that i'm
but like he baked it and i ate that [ __ ]
it was
[ __ ] amazing dude there's nothing
like homemade homemade bread is like
a lost art man it really is that [ __ ]
was
[ __ ] incredible we're deprived of
real good homemade bread because all the
[ __ ] that we eat is like
manufactured or like it's made with like
i'm telling you when i started dabbling
with sourdough
and like yeah it takes like a week to
just to get the sourdough and then you
have to feed it every day like a pet
yeah the sourdough starts elaborate okay
so basically the flavor of bread that
funky flavor
bread comes from literally going bad
like it's like this it's like this mush
that just it's alive and it goes there's
some pizza places like
in new york uh that have these these
starters that have been alive for over a
hundred years
that still they still use it for their
dough and they just keep it alive
they just keep it you have to feed it
water it's literally water and flour
every day if defeated
that's that's all you have to do and
then this thing once you feed it starts
bubbling up it comes alive
and then you mix that in with like you
mix that in with flour
whatever you're making your bread with
you let that sit you fold it you
activate it every hour you keep you keep
folding it to make it activate and then
you let it rest and then you
shape it put it in the oven and you have
something called the oven spring
it rises and then you get this nice loaf
and it tastes
amazing he did that [ __ ] with the razor
blades yeah yeah
you score it yeah jesus christ and then
it rolls out and then that [ __ ]
it looks like a flower blooming it's a
beautiful it's an art it's an art
and it's delicious do you have an app to
guide you
through the the parts because that's a
lot of
that's a lot no it's a structure it's
like for me it's a two-day effort
is this one if if you miss one step does
it just destroy the whole batch or
something no it does it's very liberal
and you know what
i've gotten to the point now where i
eyeball it so i just i walk into the
kitchen and i see where my rise is at
yeah and i'm like oh yeah whatever and
then at night i just
cover it up throw it in the fridge and
then first thing in the morning i put it
in the oven
you you here's how
just damaging and memorable crack rap is
because when you said i eyeball it i
immediately thought
oh like young jeezy with cocaine
[Laughter]
it's the same concept you're so good at
it that you could just eyeball it
yeah you know for him it's uh for him
it's more like a matter of
making more money or less money for me
it's just making good do i have crack
wrap
cooking videos yet i feel like those
would do amazingly like if somebody got
you know somebody did a really stylistic
crack cooking video
oh oh yeah they teach you how to make
drinks
yeah yeah i feel like they should go to
the moon oh
it needs to stay i mean oh no i don't
know
i don't know d by master p was pretty
much the yeah that's true
first but he has you know i don't know
the production values on that video
weren't clean it could maybe it could
using
an update a remaster
here's how you put it do this thing
here's how you
cook it up and you make it and then
i got vipers like y'all cowards don't
even smoke
that's the tour that's the tour it's
crack dealer
and crack head co-headline oh wow
and they talk and then it's a and then
it closes with a duet instead of the
the rapper trying to do all these
different personas and
i'm gonna personify the actual drug or
i'm a personifier they'll crack it
let's get a crackhead they do it instead
you're trying to right yeah and a real
crack dealer
and then yeah they can shake hands at
the end because yeah they have solved
the drug war yeah and now everybody now
everybody stop
and the crack deal is like i quit and
then the crackheads like
i quit too and then
black out the lights and we'll see you
next year
every you know we're here every
christmas eve in
butler pennsylvania yeah that's yes it's
the crowd
you couldn't do it here you couldn't do
it here there's too many temptations
too many too much too much crack use you
can't you got to do it in a place where
there's not
not as much crack use because there's
too many temptations
i mean it's too many triggers it's just
a show and i gotta do it somewhere else
even in a hypothetical
[Laughter]
even in the hypothetical it's not
realistic okay as soon as the curtain
comes down though
the crackhead is smoking crack that the
crack if he's in butler
oh that's right you know it's just a
show it's just like it's like you know
yeah
it's like they two are everywhere they
just do butler christmas eve
okay wait it's gonna be winter wait
we're gonna have special heating pots
wait crackheads don't get cold that's
the target audience
okay i like this
it could work all right you know since
live music and touring
may not be the way forward yeah i think
live
live cocaine morality plays it might be
that might be what we need to do going
forward
yeah you know hell yeah but mike let me
get let me ask you a serious question
i like serious questions uh being a
musician
honestly like what do you see the future
of this like performing and stuff like
that as a musician
i mean i don't my [ __ ] at my scale that
[ __ ] ain't coming back no time soon
yeah how how would you how long would
you estimate oh no man trying to put 300
people in a small ass room
yeah i don't know yeah i don't know i
know if if for me as a fan
i ain't rushing to do that [ __ ] so do
you think everything just has to be like
outdoor performances
until until we get like it has to start
with a reliable vaccine
and then you know even even after that
is on the market it's going to be a
while before people actually are [ __ ]
comfortable you know what i mean you
know like
and then the venues are going to have
insurance concerns and [ __ ] and like
so they might n it might be a while
before they can even legally go to full
capacity
and you know with the way [ __ ] works at
my level like if you
if the room hold 300 and you only let a
hundred people in there
that's 200 tickets not paid for exactly
so do you raise the price crazy or does
everybody
you know what i mean it becomes like an
elitist art it gets
stupid when it comes oh that's dark you
know because everybody got to pay the
rent right
you know what i mean then you can't have
like the common man or like even young
people that don't have
good income to see your shows it's just
rich snobs
i mean it ain't got it ain't got to get
to hamilton price levels but you know
what i mean like
but you know it would probably be higher
than the 20
that i would charge now you know what i
mean
i want i mean
i wonder about yeah
the how the testing would go or if
if it's you
can purchase a ticket if you're you show
up
covet test that's negative
in the past this cause
here's the thing everybody ain't got
that [ __ ]
i know it only takes one but
i feel like
i don't know yeah you know i feel
i did see something that's saying that
they think a lot of the
small venue somebody said 90 percent
are gonna close they're gonna
unless they got super funding from
somebody else or something like that
or they're looped into the lab nation
yeah somehow or something
but these independent venues no there's
no there's i can't see it i don't know
what the [ __ ]
programming they're gonna have you know
i mean they're already starting to fall
man
we're seeing the beginning of it now
so uh y'all want to go
to the trampoline park later uh maybe
you know
it looked like fun um babylon
suggested uh he sent that
and you know he sent it to me and
i was excited it was a split second yeah
and then right after it wasn't even a
full beat without
pitching myself tearing my acl yeah
easily mm-hmm
easily i already got bad feet you know
what i mean i got i got a
stressed out achilles and one of my
shits like
in a fever dream i don't know i just
pictured it it's just a
i don't know it might even not be a
reasonable i still want to go just look
just to see if there's if you know cause
i think this i looked at some other
stuff there besides just
jumping up and down just jumping up and
down there's some more focused stuff and
maybe it's uh
lower impact or oh man that's crazy they
got one of them things where you can uh
uh trampoline and dunk like trampoline
to dunk basketball
yeah yeah i'll see y'all probably for
that i might have somebody to go just a
dunk one time
what's the name it's not easy bro don't
matter it's not as easy as you think man
it's actually
easy but that's some [ __ ] i would like
to try we went
where did we go was that true kalamazoo
kalamazoo yeah
yeah we went a few years ago none of us
could do it none of us can make the dunk
it's tough it's tough levels
yeah well yeah you know
we should we should go i think what's
the hours
it closed at seven okay good i gotta
call this up
yeah we should go what time is it now
three three
forty-two yeah
i'll just say this i'm a pretty limber
dude and i hurt my knee about three
weeks ago doing nothing at all
yeah yeah yeah
and it's still [ __ ] up but it's been
it's been about a month and a half now
doing nothing but what i was i was
loading
uh back of a trap
it was the next day i woke up and i'm
like something's wrong and
the day after that it was even worse
than the day after that yeah it's always
the third day it settles in
yeah i i can't even tell you what the
motion was but that's the only thing i
can trace it back to
yeah it's moving something in the bike
at the back of the truck i've i've
reached like for this
motorcycle though yeah you said nothing
yeah use that yeah
i made it sound like you made it seem
like you like grab like oh it was like a
box of uh yeah
they may not even make the motorcycle
like i could have been me
it was probably the motorcycle though
no it's not it's definitely the
motorcycle the heaviest thing
that you tried to move like a superhero
day
man i tried to come back for this tour i
was like man i need to condition myself
i haven't been doing my thing you know
what i'm saying because i
because i got to carry that all that
gear and [ __ ] i'm like that [ __ ] takes a
toll on your body
so i'm like all right so i got back on
that vr boxing [ __ ]
yeah so i'm like first day i'm going to
take it easy right i did 10 minutes
10 minutes straight no break that [ __ ]
kicked my ass
10 minutes of vr boxing i could like
my my everything from my [ __ ] ankles
up to my [ __ ] neck was just
sore as [ __ ] for like two three days
and i couldn't believe it i couldn't
believe it
i'm completely i need to recondition all
of myself well you know we're
older men now that i mean yeah we're
entering that part of life
can't move around like yeah man you know
can't be trying to throw motorcycles in
the backs of trucks
yeah well that's just that's some [ __ ]
come on man
sure sure
how did how old are they how old are
they
young guys youth youth yeah man
i bro i broke my ass in march you caught
your tailbone yeah i broke it
it should still hurt it's [ __ ]
september that [ __ ] still hurts yeah
yeah i fell down stairs like slid
broke my whole ass yeah that's the only
way i could think yeah that's
exactly what happened i was holding some
[ __ ] loading out of a show
i missed the step
what happens when you what happened they
put a cast on your ass okay they can't
do nothing your asses just broke until
it fixes
you just walk around with a broken ass
it's still broke cause my ass is still
when you
when it was fresh broke could you sit
down yeah it would hurt but i could do
it
it just hurts it just hurts so just sit
the wrong way now
my ass will start hurting oh my god damn
yeah man
age [ __ ] ain't no joke age is is real
father time is undefeated as they say
did you know right away no i knew the
next day
because that the day i did it i was
drunk yeah exactly
i didn't feel you those kind of injuries
usually happen when you're drunk and
you don't feel them i think
about [ __ ] in a way where
i know this is the only time in my life
that i'm gonna be on an off day
on tour in butler pennsylvania
there's some absolutes and there's some
100 things yeah like this is it this is
it this is the only time i'll be
recording
podcasting hanging out off day on a
thursday
in butler pennsylvania and borrowing
some wild probabilities to happen
but i would say it's point zero zero
this is is is is this is this
is this is zero one that this will
happen again
so it was great shout out to brother
shout out to downtown butler down
downtown let's keep it specific downtown
butler shout out to these four places
that we've been
cafe was chill the chop shop
and that's that's that yeah babylon you
wanna uh
what were your thoughts on you know
performing in butler
yesterday it's great yeah
great town
uh the wings was hot
and i just want to say honestly at all
the shows we've done together
that carcino [ __ ] takes it to another
level
i'm gonna be honest with you i'm gonna
post i posted a little video
i posted a little video on instagram
and people been hitting me up
feverishly trying to figure out what
that's about they may have been talking
about my hair which they should be
yeah they trying to talk about that
marshmallow [ __ ]
yeah cause i think they know they know
what
he gets paid usually on the road
relative to what
i'm able to offer so that's just
wondering how we were able to book him
on tour and um
it was like the right to wonder that you
know what you know what it's like it's
like the equivalent to when we had john
hamm on the podcast
people like how did you get jon hamm on
the podcast or how did tony trim
get in the hollywood media line yeah
at the tag premiere these are good
questions to have
these questions these are very good
questions to ask yeah i'm
last night was was was a game changer it
was a game changer
yeah that was it was uh it was a good
time and you know cautionment bringing a
lot of great energy to the tour
um uh i'll say one of my other critiques
of last night was the
sweet country air of butler pennsylvania
made the audio sound rich
and warm honest it was you know
the summer it was sort of an indian
summer evening
it was it was a nice night no i'm saying
indian summer evening
and it felt like we were just the
headlining night
of a butler pennsylvania music festival
that was a pop-up it was a pop-up
boutique music festival comedy music
festival that popped up
definitely had festival vibes it had a
festival vibe yeah yeah
had a festival vibe to it and uh you
know we took the drone up we got some
drone shots drone
footage you know cut to drone footage
real quick
that was hilarious when you when you
started flying the drone out far
yeah i could see babylon starting to
panic a little bit
but then kev no kelvin says the babylon
he's like he's like you should probably
go
you're probably gonna stop him man i was
like help me get your nephew yeah
yeah it's like babylon doesn't move he's
just like kelvin go get your nephew
because it goes fast because you know
you you look away and you look up and
you don't see it i know i've had that
feeling yeah you're like
where the [ __ ] is it no because you
couldn't see it at one point yeah i
thought he was still i thought it was
still by the stage and this [ __ ] was
it was out yeah it was further way
further than i thought that was fun but
it was fun it felt
it was a good it's a good little
activity yeah drone life
drone life we got
today off this today is what september
24th
and then uh we got indianapolis
uh the friday we're gonna drop this is
dropping this dropping
tomorrow okay tomorrow we put we drop
this
fresh uh so
hey if you're in the indianapolis area
we'll see you there maybe
or maybe not chicago is sold out
columbus second show needs a few more
tickets chicago we're gonna do a live
stream
of the second show so the info for that
will hopefully
be below here or on here
go to i don't know i got go that
that's uh that's a new character i'm
playing called guy who
can't plug he just breaks down
[Laughter]
guys make sure to come to the show and
check it out
the link will be
my new podcast but what time's the show
is
what's the parking situation
thanks for the information man
all right for sure y'all um
yeah let's see how it goes you're right
yeah
i still live in media